happy Halloween youtubers is Charlie so
this is gonna be my Constantine episode
- video it was kind of like a second
episode one but we did get to meet the
Zed character so I'll totally explain
her history in the comics cuz she was a
really big character they did change the
show just a little after the pilot was
shot so I'll explain what they kept
namely the map which is what they're
gonna use to find new Dark Arts to
dabble in all over the United States
they really didn't change that much just
the actors change was the big thing
careful for spoilers if you're not cut
up but starting with top five moments
number five evil is spreading if it
seemed weird that they went to a really
small town for their second episode it
was just to highlight the fact that evil
is spreading everywhere not just creepy
gothic cities like Gotham it's all part
of that shadow Constantine demon plot
that they teased in episode one the
miners did tunnel into supernatural area
but that's not what made all the Koblin
out go crazy didn't help either this
nameless darkness is just throwing
gasoline on the flames that's what gave
the Gypsy woman's power that extra juice
I totally don't expect them to explain
what's going on with this at least for a
couple more episodes we need to learn
more about what's going on with the
inner circle of demons and that's plan
not gonna happen for a while number four
the Kobler now spirits there aren't a
whole lot of details about these spirits
from the comics but in classic mythology
they're pretty close to Cave goblins in
the episode they're just the spirits of
miners that were killed inside the mine
remember Constantine explained that
spirits you can see on earth are trapped
they're not supposed to be here that's
why heaven was so freaked out in the
first episode more evil things are
manifesting in places that they
shouldn't be able to
that's what manis doing here that's why
he's trying to enlist Constantine's help
even if it looks like he's trolling him
most of the time the mining operation
just shook the spirits up a little bit
they were just down there minding their
own business
the Gypsy is what turned them into
killers that's what Constantine's big
save was all about down in the mind he
just reminded them that they're not evil
it's getting a lot easier for them to do
things like this on television with
visual effects so expect to see more
cool looking creatures this season they
won't just be dealing with demons it'll
be all manner of spirits and
supernatural creatures visually they
reminded me of Melisandre smoked baby
from Game of Thrones number three
Constantine dabbles in the dark arts I
don't think him casting the spell in the
jar water was dark magic but I was
excited to finally see him you
his powers in a visual way he does
actually have real supernatural powers
most of the time though he works through
other agents like Zed who have much more
specific abilities one of the big
aspects of this character from the
comics is that he has a lot of people
like Zed who have supernatural abilities
that he works with from time to time
Constantine supernatural ability just
allows him to create his own luck he
uses it to talk his way out of
situations he's claimed to have pulled a
fast one on both Lucifer and God
so whenever Zed asked him what he was
gonna use for protection and he just
said my wits that's what he was talking
about when he's on his game he could
talk his way out of everything but he is
a pretty epic mess of a human being
so his wits aren't going to save him
from getting his ass handed to him every
week I would expect him to get punched
in the face at least once per episode
now that we have the zeg character
that's gonna happen a lot more just in a
much more playful way number two you
need faith to raise evil Constantine was
able to raise the dead husband's spirits
so he must have a little bit of faith in
him he does despise both heaven and hell
but his spells wouldn't have any power
at all if he didn't have faith that was
also a big callback to that first
episode when shadow Constantine said his
spells like the power of conviction I
expect them to pay that ID off a few
more times his faith will be tested
he'll fail then I'll have some big epic
success against one of the big villains
all part of the hero's journey him
raising the evil spirit was also a nice
callback to his story about Astrid being
drugged to help by a demon he raised
that's gonna be one of the bigger arcs I
don't know if they'll take the series
that far in season 1 something I'm
hoping we see but that they haven't
promised is that Constantine will
actually go to hell like he'll travel to
Hell physically he'll have to do that to
say bastard anyway so we might get to
see that and my number 1 moment of
course meet Zed Martin so if you haven't
read the comics Zed is from Hellblazer
she appeared for the first time in
Hellblazer number 4 so she's totally
old-school during her run in the comics
she and Constantine had an on-again
off-again sexual relationship so that's
why they were so playful in the episode
she's the female lead on a network show
so she'd have to have sexual chemistry
with her co-star but they pushed it much
much further because it was a big thing
in the comics one of her biggest
storylines was Resurrection Crusade she
ended up getting targeted by this cult
led by her father to become the vessel
for the next Messiah
because she had sex with Constantine the
night before the whole thing got botched
and she did not survive that was after a
long run in the comics and I don't think
there's any way that they're gonna kill
aunt helices celaya off
that's the actors that plays dead so
just expect them to avoid that storyline
in the comics all in total Zed was in a
little over 30 issues I know that
doesn't seem like a long time but it was
she's a huge deal so I'm really happy
that the show is doing her let me know
that what was your favorite moment from
the episode and what do you think about
the Z character so far while you guys
think about that to here a couple Easter
eggs that I spotted first are
Constantine's tattoos we only see them
on him in the episode but the movie made
them a really big thing like they
actually do things they're proprietary
blend like he likes to say of custom
runes we also got a much better look it
says charcoal drawings they're all
covers of big Hellblazer comics let me
know that if you did spot any other
Easter eggs in the episode that I didn't
list just write them below in the
comments overall I gave the episode a
solid beat I thought it was stronger
than the pilot but pilots changed so
much usually second episodes are way
better all the time
producers and writers are just able to
fix things they don't think worth recast
actors that they need to just make any
of the changes they feel they need to
make to make the show better I think
it's gonna be a few more episodes before
we find the rhythm of these characters
and even though I totally loved Lucy
Griffiths I feel like the Zed character
is a much better foil for Constantine I
am gonna give them a few episodes before
I pass judgment but so far I'm totally
loving their energy they have a very
honeymoon suite kind of energy next week
I think the other main characters are
back so we should get to see the full
team in action
the real purpose of this episode was to
intro that said character I loved the
way they played that ending to their
presenting her as equal parts bad and
good for Constantine they have this
weird symbiotic relationship where
they're really awesome together and
really bad for each other at the same
time so I am excited to see them get
into a lot of trouble together I feel
like that's gonna be half the fun just
watching them get into bad situations
next week though Papa midnite from the
comics is coming on so be sure to
subscribe to get my video I'll post it
right after the episode airs heads up to
Doctor Who finale happening over the
next two weeks it's a two-parter so be
sure to check it out is gonna be
freaking crazy
so in case you haven't seen it yet you
can click here for my Constantine
episode 1 video and you
click here to learn about Constantine's
history in the comics thank you so much
for watching so let's all high five and
I'll see you guys this weekend
you